this keyboard can make you better at
Shooters this keyboard gives you a
competitive advantage and I'm not even
joking I can't use any other keyboard
after using this one starting last year
tons of Cs and valerant Pros all started
switching to this the wooting 60h top
FPS players swear that the wooting will
objectively make you better at any game
that requires precise keyboard movement
but why well the wooting uses analog
switches unlike your keyboards
mechanical ones that means the wooting
keys don't just have one actuation point
and can be endlessly customized to be
exactly as sensitive or responsive as
you need basically if you want to walk
counter strafe or jiggle Peak more
carefully it's a lot easier and more
precise with the wooting the difference
of a few milliseconds can be the
difference between like being accurate
or inaccurate or being alive or being
dead and which ultimately can result in
winning the round or winning the game